OVERTURNING IT.
JOHN AVALON WITH OUR REALITY
CHECK TODAY, THANK YOU.
>>> THE ANNUAL MET GALA WAS HELD
IN NEW YORK AND ON FASHION'S
THAT COST MORE THAN
$30,000 PER TICKET.
JOINING ME NOW IS THE WOMAN WHO
DESIGNED THE GOWN, AURORA JAMES.
SHE IS THE FOUNDER AND CREATIVE
DIRECTOR OF BROTHER VELLIS.
WE GOT TO SEE YOU THERE AS WELL
ON THE RED CARPET STANDING BY
YOUR CREATION THERE.
I WONDER, FIRST THINGS FIRST,
CAN YOU JUST TELL US THE BACK
STORY OF HOW YOU CAME TO DESIGN
THIS?
>> YES, OF COURSE.
SO, WHEN IT CAME TO DRESSING THE
CONGRESSWOMAN FOR THIS EVENT,
YOU KNOW, I WANTED TO MAKE
SOMETHING REALLY SPECIAL FOR
HER, AND ULTIMATELY --
>> CAN I BACK PEDAL?
HOW -- DO YOU KNOW HER?
HOW DID IT COME TO BE THAT YOU
GOT PICKED TO DO THIS?
>> WELL, I THINK WE'VE BOTH BEEN
FAMILIAR WITH EACH OTHER'S WORK
FOR A LITTLE WHILE.
I STARTED MY BUSINESS HERE IN
NEW YORK WITH $3,500 AT THE FLEA
MARKET.
WHEN SHE WAS STILL BARTENDING,
SHE WAS FOLLOWING MY WORK AND
SHE WAS SO EXCITED WHEN I WON
SOMETHING CALLED THE CFDA VOTE
FASHION FUND JUST, YOU KNOW,
BEING A WORKING CLASS GIRL AND
IMMIGRANT HERE IN NEW YORK
LAUNCHING A FASHION BRAND IT'S
PRETTY UNHEARD OF TO MAKE IT IN
THE UPPER ECHELON OF LUXURY
FASHION.
SHE REALLY FOLLOWED MY CAREER
AND WE DECIDED TO COLLABORATE ON
THIS LOOK.
>> OKAY.
SO, THEN, YOU'RE COLLABORATING
ON THE LOOK AND TELL US HOW YOU
CONCEIVE OF THIS DESIGN.
>> WELL, YOU KNOW, THE MET GALA
OBVIOUSLY IS ONE OF THE MOST
EXCLUSIVE EVENTS IN THE WORLD,
AND WE WANTED TO COME AND
DELIVER A MESSAGE.
AND I THINK WHEN WE TALK ABOUT
INCLUSION AND GAINING ACCESS TO
CLOSED ROOMS FOR PEOPLE OF
COLOR, WHEN YOU FINALLY GET A
SEAT AT THE TABLE, YOU HAVE TO
DECIDE WHAT THE MESSAGE IS THAT
YOU WANT TO DELIVER.
AND I THINK FOR THE
CONGRESSWOMAN, I THINK FOR
MYSELF, ECONOMIC EQUALITY AND
ECONOMIC JUSTICE WAS SORT OF TOP
OF MIND.
AND TAX THE RICH WAS REALLY WHAT
WE SETTLED ON.
>> THERE'S A LOT OF RICH PEOPLE
AT THIS EVENT.
IT'S INCREDIBLY EXPENSIVE TO
ATTEND.
IT IS INCREDIBLY EXCLUSIVE, AND
THERE ARE FOLKS, ESPECIALLY ON
THE RIGHT, WHO ARE CRITICIZING
THE CONGRESSWOMAN, SAYING SHE'S
MAKING THIS MESSAGE, BUT THIS IS
SOME HOITY-TOITY EVENT.
WHAT IS YOUR MESSAGE TO THE
BACKLASH?
>> I THINK ULTIMATELY, A LOT OF
THESE CONVERSATIONS THAT WE HAVE
ABOUT ECONOMIC JUSTICE USUALLY
HAPPEN IN SPACES WITH WORKING
CLASS PEOPLE.
AND I THINK THE CONGRESSWOMAN IS
NOT GOING TO EVER SACRIFICE HER
MORALS FOR COMFORT.
AND SHE WANTED TO MAKE SURE THAT
THIS MESSAGE WAS BROUGHT INTO
THAT ROOM AND INTO A GROUP OF
PEOPLE WHO ULTIMATELY HAVE TO BE
WILLING TO, YOU KNOW, BE MORE
LIBERAL WITH THEIR ECONOMIC
VALUES AS WELL.
AND I THINK THAT'S WHAT WE'VE
DONE.
AND TO BE HONEST WITH YOU, SHE
WOULDN'T HAVE ATTENDED AND JUST
WORN A PRETTY GOWN WITHOUT
DELIVERING ANY KIND OF MESSAGE
TO PEOPLE.
AND, YOU KNOW, FASHION IS OFTEN
THOUGHT OF AS THIS REALLY
FRIVOLOUS THING THAT ULTIMATELY
IN MY BRAND AND FOR A LOT OF
OTHER DESIGNERS, WE USE IT AS A
REALLY POWERFUL TOOL FOR
COMMUNICATION, ESPECIALLY WOMEN
OF COLOR.
I HAVE BEEN A SUSTAINABLE
DESIGNER SINCE I STARTED IN
2013.
I ALSO USED MY COMPANY TO LAUNCH
ONE OF THE FASTEST-GROWING
NONPROFITS IN AMERICA RIGHT NOW,
THE 15% PLEDGE.
IT'S REALLY ABOUT TAKING THE
ACCESS THAT YOU HAVE AND SHARING
A MESSAGE.
AND I THINK THAT THAT'S WHAT
SHE'S DONE.
AND ULTIMATELY, THE MORE WE CAN
PUT OUT THESE IDEAS INTO POPULAR
CULTURE, POLITICS WILL ALSO
FOLLOW THAT.
>> CAN I ASK YOU REAL QUICK, HOW
MUCH DID THE DRESS COST, AND ARE
YOU GETTING THIS DRESS BACK?
>> YES.
SO, THE DRESS I MADE, AND WE
CREATED THE WHOLE THING RIGHT
HERE IN NEW YORK.
I HAVEN'T CALCULATED ALL OF OUR
COSTS YET, BUT WE USED A LOT OF
SALVAGED MATERIALS WHICH IS
REALLY AMAZING AND IMPORTANT TO
ME JUST BECAUSE SUSTAINABILITY
IS AT THE FOREFRONT OF
EVERYTHING THAT I DO.
AND I LENT IT TO HER FOR THE
NIGHT.
I THINK IT'S A SUPER SPECIAL
PIECE.
WE CREATED A REALLY POWERFUL
MESSAGE THERE.
>> YOU HAVE CAUGHT A LOT OF
EYEBALLS AND A LOT OF ATTENTION
CERTAINLY IN PUTTING THIS DRESS
OUT THERE.
AURORA JAMES, THANK YOU SO MUCH
FOR BEING WITH US.
>> THANK YOU FOR HAVING ME.
>> YOU CAN'T WEAR A DRESS LIKE
THAT AGAIN.
>> PEOPLE WOULD KNOW.
YOU DON'T WANT TO REPEAT.
IT'S LIKE WEARING A WEDDING
DRESS IN A WAY.
NOT GOING TO WEAR IT AGAIN.
>>> FOR MORE ON THIS I WANT TO
BRING IN COMMENTATOR S.E. CUPP.
THE MET GALA IS MY PERSONAL
HELP.
THE IDEA OF DRESSING UP WITH
HOITY-TOITY PEOPLE AS BRIANNA
SAYS AFTER 9:00 P.M., I CAN'T
THINK OF ANYTHING WORSE.
THE QUESTION ABOUT THIS DRESS
IS, YOU KNOW, IS ALEXANDRIA
OCASIO-CORTEZ, IS IT SOMEHOW
HYPOCRITICAL FOR HER GOING TO
THIS CLEARLY ELITIST THING, EVEN
DELIVERING THAT MESSAGE?
>> I DON'T KNOW THAT IT'S
HYPOCRITICAL PER SE.
AND, YOU KNOW, I'VE DEFENDED
A.O.C. ON HER $300 HAIRCUTS.
I'M REALLY TRYING TO SEE THIS
NOT AS A PARTISAN.
I DO THINK THE MESSAGE IS
CONFUSED, THOUGH.
IT LOOKS A LITTLE LIKE, YOU
KNOW, SHE WANTED TO HAVE HER
CAKE AND EAT IT, TOO.
SHE WANTED TO GO TO THE, YOU
KNOW, VERY ELITE, I THINK VERY
COOL EVENT THAT IN MANY WAYS
CELEBRATES ART, BUT ALSO
CELEBRATES EXCESS.
AND SHE WANTED TO WEAR AN
EXPENSIVE, YOU KNOW, CUSTOM
DESIGNER GOWN, WHICH SHE DID.
SHE WANTED TO HAVE HER HAIR AND
MAKEUP DONE BY CELEBRITY
STYLISTS WHICH SHE DID.
SHE WANTED TO GET READY AT THE
CARLISLE HOTEL, A NICE RITZY
GLITZY HOTEL IN NEW YORK, AND
SHE DID.
AND SHE WANTED TO RUB ELBOWS
WITH CELEBRITIES.
WHICH SHE DID.
ALL THE WHILE HOPING TO DRAW
ATTENTION TO A MESSAGE THAT, I
MEAN, ARE WE TALKING ABOUT
ECONOMIC INEQUALITY TODAY OR ARE
WE TALKING ABOUT THE STUNT?
AND SO I'M NOT SURE HOW
SUCCESSFUL IT WAS.
I DO LIKE THAT SHE'S PROMOTING A
SUSTAINABLE DESIGNER, A DESIGNER
WHO CARES ABOUT PUTTING BLACK
PRODUCTS ON SHELVES.
I LOVE BROTHER VALLEY'S
ACCESSORIES AND SHOES.
THEY'RE $700 SHOES, $1600 BAGS.
THEY'RE GORGEOUS.
I HOPE AURORA JAMES HAS A BOOST
IN SALES FROM THIS.
I'M JUST NOT SURE WE'VE TACKLED
ECONOMIC INEQUALITY WITH THIS
STUNT.
>> YOU KNOW, I THINK THAT'S A
VERY INTERESTING QUESTION.
WHAT ARE WE TALKING ABOUT?
>> ACTUALLY, THANK YOU TO S.E.
FOR PUTTING THIS --
>> I'VE BEEN TRYING TO FIGURE
OUT HOW TO THINK ABOUT THIS.
ON ONE HAND, LIKE YOU SAID, IT
IS AN EXPENSIVE BRAND.
ON THE OTHER HAND, IF YOU LOOK
AT THE WEBSITE, SHE IS A BLACK
CREATOR IN A LARGELY WHITE SPACE
PROMOTING BLACK MODELS, YOU
KNOW, SHE'S DOING A LOT.
>> YEAH.
>> TO ADVANCE, YOU KNOW, WHAT
SHE DOES IN A PLACE WHERE PEOPLE
OF COLOR SO OFTEN SHUT OUT OR
UNDER REPRESENTED.
>> AND I LOVE HER STUFF.
JUST AS A CONSUMER.
I LOVE HER STUFF.
SO, AGAIN, I HOPE SHE DOES WELL.
I'M ASSUMING T